What's a vision statement and
how do you get started writing one for
your business?
A vision statement is a declaration
of your company objectives,
meant to provide guidance
on the decisions you make.
Basically, it's the big dream
that you have for your business.
You can think of it as the Northstar for
your company.
It helps provide inspiration about what
your business is focused on achieving
throughout its lifetime.
There's a few basic questions
that a vision statement should
be able to answer.
Try focusing on questions like these.
What will your business become if
everything goes according to plan?
Why do you exist?
And how will your business
change the world?
You don't want to state specific
ways you go about doing this yet,
just focus on the overarching goal that
you as a business plan to work towards.
And finally,
it's important to consider how long
your vision statement might need to be.
There's really no set length for
a vision statement, but
there's a few guidelines you
can follow to help write yours.
You want to make sure you have enough
information to provide a sense of
purpose, a call to action and
an idea of your final destination.
You don't want it to be so
long that it's difficult to understand.
But making it too short can also leave
out the kind of meaning it will need to
actually guide your business.
One line vision statements
are possible but
you could have a full paragraph
if that's what it takes.
Just consider that if you want
people to actually read and
remember this, then brief can be better.
Don't be so
broad that you sound generic, but not so
specific that it won't be
relevant after a couple years.
For example,
Google's vision is to provide access to
the world's information in one click.
Do you notice how their vision focuses
on a bold claim about the overarching
goal they have for their business?
Try doing the same for yours.
So, consider some of these ideas and
look into some of the examples of vision
statements created by other companies.
Once you feel comfortable with
the purpose of a vision statement,
try thinking of one that you
could use for your business.